what's it like having everybody back
together it's wonderful we had a party
last night and it was so kind of it was
so strange because it's never been so
long since we've all been together so
kind of coming together now feels like
our first like school reunion really how
was the party last night what did y'all
do oh look Sharon Sharon right now is
losing her mind wearing stilts it is
rarely the mrs. Oh is at a loss for
words
well I'm incredibly flattered but I mean
I love the whole help but I mean that
scene was a that was a showstopper yeah
yeah in many ways tell me about the
party last night
oh yeah so the body was excellent it was
very good but I tried to leave it you
know it's a reasonable hour because we
got to get our beauty sleep with this
red carpet right here okay so what about
the party tonight
well that there's no red carpet tomorrow
we are getting ellipse are you are you
going all in yes I can't wait to see all
that for the outcome the results will be
the same
okay sure Sharon is really loose she's
losing her mind right now good luck
tonight
oh one more thing did you ever yeah okay
so I think that j.lo in hustlaz is the
greatest introduction of a character I
have ever seen I heckled in the cinema
I'm English I don't do that but I did so
JLo is my inspiration for this evening I
plan on channeling her all night long
you're channeling the hell out of JLo
okay can we ask you one question if they
caught this is you in the square when
they're announcing your category right
and if they call your name what's your
reaction if they call someone else's
name go get your award go in there get
your
[Music]